Chris: Sally hold on, I got a call *phone
ringing*
Chris: Chris Waters.
John: Hey, how's it going man?
Chris: Good John, how are you?
J: I'm good, are we going to do this meet
in the middle thing?
I think it's technically public property,
right, because it's on the creek?
C: Technically public property located perhaps
behind the largest house in Indianapolis.
J: I'll also bring Eugenia Price's Beauty
from Ashes if you bring a little, uh, a snack.
C: Do you think Jimmy John's will deliver
if we give 'em the coordinates?
J: *laughter*
C: Alright, thank goodness I wore my speedo
today since we're going on the creek.
Time to go swimmin'.
J: Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's actually Saturday but it will be Tuesday
in the fullness of time.
So Sarah's new show with PBS, The Art Assignment,
just premiered.
What she does is she goes around the country
visiting with working artists, we get to see
some of their work, some art historical context
for it and then they give us an art assignment.
J: I have to pick a friend and then meet that
person at the exact geographical midpoint
between the two of us.
Now many of you will be wondering: How is
this art?
Well, you should watch the first episode of
The Art Assignment.
So anyway my best friend Chris and I chose
each other and now we have to make our way
here by 2 o'clock.
C: It is 1:03 PM.
Is art just some guy going on a hike with
his dog to arbitrarily meet a friend that
he set up an appointment with three hours
ago?
There's a certain excitement to it, nervousness
about it.
J: Not going to lie, I'm pretty nervous right
now.
Hank, one of the things this assignment makes
me think about is public and private space.
Like on this side of the fence, those trees
belong to someone.
But on this side of the fence the trees belong
to everyone.
That's odd.
Ok we have reached Williams Creek.
C: Leaving the road.
There's trusty Mya.
J: The craziest thing about this is that I'm
right in the middle of the city of Indianapolis,
a city of one million people, and, like, it's
just forest.
Ah, this is intense.
I'm gonna have to get down on my hands and
knees.
C: Not an easy hike.
I've been on my hands and knees trying to
get through this.
J: Ok, here we go.
Hoo, down into the creek.
*heavy breathing*
C: Okay, comin' up on the last spot
J: Honestly if I didn't have to meet Chris
at this point I would give up because the
brush is so thick.
I don't want him sitting there, you know,
worrying about me or whatever.
Wow, look at this, this is so beautiful.
Wow.
Yeah, that's not something I would have seen
today.
I just heard a noise.
Hup, oh I see him, I see him!
C: Some call him Jeremiah Johnson, some call
him Davy Crockett, but what he is is a frontiersman.
And I think he's wearing his fancy Amsterdam
jacket.
Like a spry jungle cat springing in to the
spring snow.
Sic 'im, Mya.
J: *breathing heavily* Oh, hey, Chris.
C: Hey, John.
J: How's it goin'?
C: Fancy seeing you here
J: Good to see ya.
Come in for the real stuff.
I'm so beat up, man.
C: *chuckles*
J: Ahh.
C: Let me just look, let's look at that outfit.
Let's look at-
J: Aoh, my whole idea was to go as someone
who's really super professional, you know?
Who has a...
Like maybe a businessman who just got lost
in the woods.
J: Ahh, it's just so beautiful, man.
C: Yeah.
J: It's such a cool thing that we wouldn't
have done today.
C: No.
J: You know?
Like there's no way we would have ever done
this.
C: No.
J: Thanks for bringing the Jimmy John's.
C: Jimmy John's.
J: So I brought you a book actually, that
I thought you might enjoy.
It's called, uh, Beauty from Ashes.
It's by a wo- a writer named Eugenia Price,
you ever heard of her?
C: No, I thought it was going to be an unnecessary
plug for The Fault in Our Stars.
J: No, no.
It's just Beauty from Ashes.
C: Oh, it sounds like a good book.
J: And it is a good book!
C: It did make me think that this is how people
travelled-
J: Mhm.
C: -200 years ago.
J: And agreeing to meet at a certain time
and not having any way to contact each other
if they can't, you know?
C: I did feel like a kid again, though.
J: Yeah.
I haven't felt that kind of sense of adventure
since I was a kid.
It's fun.
C: You need to get out more.
J: Well, I don't know.
The internet's its own kind of adventure.
So we've met in the middle, we've had our
lunch and now we're gonna walk out together,
isn't that romantic?
C: It was a delicious Jimmy Johns lunch sandwich-
J: Oh, yeah.
Thank you to Jimmy Johns.
C: Thank you to Jimmy Johns and thank you
to John for bringing the, uh, wonderful novel
that we shared.
J: Hank, don't forget to be awesome, I'll
see you on Friday.
C: Are you gonna post this as your video for
Tuesday?
J: Yeah.